coup dur pour l'open de france de golf
l'european tour l'organisateur des
tournois européens décidé de lui retirer
son statut de rolex séries en 2010 9
août d'un sponsor assez important le
rendez vous est donc éjecté des huit
tournois les plus importants du vieux
continent des classes et ils ne sont pas
être comment rapproprier l'open change
de date
ces certitudes mais déclassé il reste
toute façon une épreuve du héros
penneteau ça ne vient pas il décroche
tchatche tour donc on utilise en général
le terme des classes et quand une
épreuve où une équipe passe de première
division à deuxième division ce n'est
clairement pas le cas mais c'est pas à
l'aune d'une édition qu' il faut évaluer
la valeur d'une épreuve
il faut essayer de remettre aussi tous
un petit peu en perspective autre
changement le tournoi sera déplacé dans
le calendrier 2010 neuf lots rendez vous
ne se jouera plus la dernière semaine de
juin golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais du 17 au 20 octobre
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de dates avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec leur au mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant placés en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire il reste
encore une inconnue sur le prochain open
de france la dotation elle devrait
passer de 7 millions de dollars un peu
moins de 3 millions d'euros suite à la
perte de son statut le plateau de
joueurs devraient par conséquent être
moins relevé